Okay. Here we are in our get coords function.
If we get content back from that URL we run this code.
Now, I don't have the return statement here, because I want to change this just a little bit.
In the quiz, I had you return lat, long.
What I want to return here is db.GeoPt(lat, long),
which I have learned is a part of Google App Engine.
It's a data type for storing a latitude and longitude.
We could just store a tuple here.
I figure if Google gives us a data type specifically for a location, that's what we should use.
I'm going to use one of these, and that's what we're going to return out of our function.
Let's test that this function is working.
A quick way we can do that is just toss in a line right here.
We're going to say self.write(repr(getcoords(self.request.remoteaddr))).
What I've added here is just a quick little hacky thing in our get( ) function.
First we're just going to call this function write( ), which--if you recall--I added up here,
and it calls self.response.out.write( ), so I don't have to type so much.
I can just say .write. Then we're going to call repr( ).
Now, this is a handy little trick when you're printing Python objects in HTML.
Because when you print a Python object, it has angle brackets around it,
which the browser will interpret as a tag, and then it won't actually print what you're trying to print.
If you print repr around it, you'll get some extra quotes, and it'll print properly.
Then I'm just going to call our function get_coords( ),
and I'm going to call it with the requesting IP address,
which is the remote_addr attribute of the request object.
I learned how to do this just by looking in the App Engine docs.
Almost every web framer will give you access to the requesting IP.
I knew what I was kind of looking for and just found that in docs.
Let's give this a shot. I reloaded the page, and I see None up here.
That's better than an exception. We didn't get a location.
So let's do some investigating.
The first thing I want to do is I want to see what the IP was,
so we can kind of debug this service.
Let's say self.write( ). We'll print the IP as well. Let's give that a shot.
Ah. Okay. 127.0.0.1. That means we're running this locally.
It's not surprising that a service on the internet doesn't know what our local IP is.
Let's verify that. We'll go to their API. We'll put in the API by hand, and we'll run it.
And, yes, it's a private address.
For those of you who don't know, every machine's local IP address is 127.0.0.1.
This is called the loop-back address.
This is how a machine refers to itself.
It's not a public IP address on the internet.
Local host--what we're accessing here--generally refers to that IP.
Let's cheat a little bit and see if we can fix this.
This is something that's going to come up during development.
For our period here, I'm just going to overwrite the IP we send in this function
to be an IP that I know is real--4.2.2.2.
This is a big-name server than helps you resolve TNS names into IPs.
We'll just hardcode the IP in this function to be this for now,
so we have something to actually test against.
Let's go back in our browser, give this page as reload, and see if we get anything useful.
Ah-ha. So we are now seeing the coordinates of that IP address
where that machine is located, or at least where this free service claims
that machine is located, which is fine for us.
We're not trying to be too accurate here. We just want to draw a pretty map.
Our get IP function is working.
We also conveniently tested the error case, which you should always do.
We're in good shape there. Undo those hacks, and let's check back to our to-do list.